Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Kunner's another video on autoimmune bakes basics 201
Why test for foods? I don't have any food sensitivities. Why should I test for foods? What what does that make any sense?
It makes a huge difference with autoimmune issues
If you have chronic mold chronic line, you know you have Hashimoto's you know you've been diagnosed with an autoimmune disease and you don't do
correct food
Diagnostics on your blood you are missing out and you're still having struggles that you're really missing out
You got your autoimmune disease really under control and you're not having any symptoms
Well, then that's great. You don't need this video, but for those who there autoimmune disease
Flares
causes them
Misery you really need to test for what other things are causing these flares what other things are
Causing damage to your body. So we're gonna dig into this
So remember the stages of autoimmune disease stage one silent autoimmune disease. You may show elevated antibodies in
A specific antibody test, but you really have no symptoms no loss of tissue no problems
But remember you can move from stage one to stage two to stage three
Literally overnight. So knowing that you have antibodies to self-tissue
Let's say you have Hashimoto's you have TPO antibodies. They're elevated. You don't even have any thyroid symptoms
Your thyroid levels are within normal level
You don't have tissue destruction. You're in stage one. You can flip to stage three
Literally overnight stage two as you're starting to develop symptoms
Don't have loss of tissue yet
So in that case with thyroid TPO antibodies you might have fatigue
Issues you might have some loss of hair you might have other low thyroid
Thyroid symptoms that could go along with Hashimoto's
But you don't you still have no blood levels of your TSH you T3
T4 your reverse T3 and such
And then stage three you have the elevated antibodies you have symptoms and now you have measurable tissue
Destruction go wait until you get to that level
Most people that are watching this video are at that level. So
There's still hope we got to dig in
You know most common thing we hear is you know
I've been to everywhere and I've spent thousands and thousands and thousands of dollars
Well, I am gonna ask you if you're gonna be wise to spend a few more hundred dollars on some proper testing
Because it can literally change your life, okay?
And you don't need a doctor to help you if you follow this course and
You do these tests. I'm gonna teach you through proper interpretation of the test the best I can
Then you could help manage yourself and manage your life because so much of it is what you're gonna do
Not what a doctor is gonna do to you. It's gonna be what you're gonna do with the knowledge that you don't have
So some key concepts that we need to know about dietary protein and mutatory activity
I'd understand a lot of this is coming from doctor to tease crations work a lot of this is coming from
Cyrex's lamb work
So I want to give credit to where credit is due I put doctor to tease his
Credits on each slide because I he has been my major mentor and I want to give him all the
The credit for
TGB everything I know so
So some key concepts
This is a key one dietary proteins change
Their antigenicity if they're cooked or they're raw so you need to do an immunoglobulin test
With cooked and raw foods
Really really super important a cooked protein is different than a raw protein
If you did a test other than Cyrex Labs most likely all they were tested was the raw
Food substance they're not testing for cooked food
So unless you're eating everything raw it's not a really valid test whatsoever
And if they're not doing a immunoglobulin testing, it's really not a valiant valid test at all
So you have to look at Cyrex Labs who we're gonna talk about that. I have zero dollar
You know connection with Cyrex Labs. It's just that they're the best lab on the market
Next dietary proteins can change their antigenicity where they're combined with other foods very cooking
Or even combined with other foods during the eating
Oh, how do I know oh my gosh
This gets very confusing for the person who's got an autoimmune issue who's getting all these flares who can't get off the couch
It can be because of what you ate together
You know in your meal last night
Third dietary proteins can cross react with other food proteins
So they can cross react with other proteins in other foods
Fourth dietary proteins can cross react with our own body tissue proteins
Perfect example of that will go through some more examples, but a perfect example is that is gluten with your thyroid
The TPO antibody is a molecular mimic to gluten
So if you eat gluten and you have positive TPO antibodies, you can fire an immune reaction and start damaging your thyroid gland
That's why I don't care whether you did testing or not if you have
Hashimoto's you better not be eating any gluten
You can say the same thing
KC antibodies can cross react with gluten
That's one of the cross reactants with gluten is KC which is dairy
Which can then fire TPO antibodies and a person that has
TPO antibodies that is Hashimoto's that is positive antibodies for the thyroid gland
Shouldn't be eating gluten or should they really be eating dairy now there's testing that can be done
We're going to talk about the Syrex 3x the Syrex 4 and the Syrex 10 tests that can measure these but
Some of the work has to be done by just clinical observation and I mean that
But what you do on yourself boy when I eat this I tend to have a reaction I tend to feel or tire the next day
I tend to
Just to feel achy my joints hurt my muscles hurt
You have to pay attention to this
And lastly on this list dietary proteins can induce
immune reactivity by either specific cross reactivity or by direct immune pathway activation
So we'll talk about these things in more detail
So foods and autoimmunity they could cause cross reactivity reactions
That's where it gets very confusing and you have to do some deeper tests to find out these things
And you have to look at cross reactive
Food pattern. So we're going to have all those downloadable documents
There's different cross reactive foods with KC there's different cross reactive foods with
With scallops. There's different cross reactive foods with Tuna
There's different cross reactive foods. So if you're positive
Let's say and you're testing for Tuna sensitivity
You might go, gosh, I don't even eat Tuna. I don't even like Tuna
I'm never eating Tuna in my life. How could I possibly be
Positive for the peptides the amino acid sequences in Tuna
It's because the amino acid sequences in Tuna can be very similar to other amino acid sequence
i.e. that is a cross reactive food. So well, maybe it's the cross reactive food for Tuna
Happens to be tilapia and happens to be salmon and happens to be other things that you may eat a lot of
And that's why Tuna is coming at positive. So you might not eat Tuna
But you can eat the cross reactive food and you don't think you're having a reaction
But that is actually what's causing the immune reaction and then you get the direct immune
Pathway activation, which is a little bit easier to understand
But it's that cross reactive interaction that could be the one that's stabbing in the back
And if you don't identify those things, you can never seem to get better
That's the person who I just can't get better
I'm staying away from all these foods and I just can't get better
We have to identify what these are so you can best take care of yourself
The antigenicity of individual
Dietary proteins can be changed when combined with other food proteins
So super important
So I may not react to salmon and I may not react to potatoes
But when I have salmon and potatoes together
Cooked together they can actually change the protein structure
They can combine it with that combination takes place
I can react to that. That's one problem with lactants
That we'll talk about later
There's that it tends to cause a glutenation which that term means proteins are combining together
And you end up forming new proteins, neo proteins that you're reacting to these neo proteins
Very frustrating
So you have to pay attention to real world combining
Meaning like daily I notice what I eat this and this together
I have a reaction but if I eat just potatoes I'm fine
But if I eat potatoes with salmon then I have a problem
I seem to not feel good that
Rest of that day what is it I can't figure that out
There may be a certain prepared food that you're buying
So muffin let's say it's gluten free
But I react when I eat this certain brand of gluten free muffin
But I don't react when I eat this one
Well it could be a couple of things
Could be a cross-reactive thing that you're eating
Maybe you have cross-reactivity with a different type of starch or almond flour
And you're eating a gluten free almond flour
But you actually react to almond and you never did the test
That's why it's beneficial to do the testing
All right, 3x, 4 and 10
We'll go into detail about that
Or it could be a real world combination of that food
That it's just the combination of these different things
That together they're forming neo proteins
And I'm reacting to the neo proteins that's formed
With that muffin is cooked
So we have to pay attention to these things
But we need to do the testing
To get our kind of our plan of attack down
But then we need to pay attention to real world life things
I tend to react to this specific product
Okay, so in the case of an immune reaction
If two food proteins share similar sequences of amino acids
That antibodies made for one protein
By buying to the similar amino acid sequence of another protein
So an example
The consumed food has an amino acid sequence of this slide
Foods not consumed have a very similar amino acid sequence
So, but this example is
Okay, let's say I'm not consuming these certain foods
Because I have a reaction to it
But now I'm reacting to these other foods
That did not show positive on my test
It's because they have very similar amino acid sequences
That's what we call cross-reaction
And that's what we have to pay attention to
Here's just a pretty picture of some cross-reactivity things
Now I'm going to give you very detailed cross-reactance to all these different foods
So that downloadable format on this module
So you can look at them in detail
If you do these testings
But we'll go to the top of the list
A legume, let's say I have a food sensitivity to it
It's showing positive for peanut
But it's not showing positive for peas, lentils, and beans
But I tend to react when I eat peas
What's the deal with that?
Because there's a very similar amino acid sequence
Therefore you can get cross-reactant reactions from these other foods
Do you understand?
Even though peas didn't show positive on my test
I may still have a reaction to peas
Because it's a very similar amino acid sequence
And that cross-reaction
Then my body can pick up and it stimulates an antibody reaction when I eat peas
Even though I don't have antibodies to peas
I only have antibodies to peanuts
That's what a cross-reaction is
And in this article that was published
It's shown about a 5% risk with peanuts cross-reaction with these
Don't pay attention to that
You're going to have to pay attention to real world things that are going on in your life
Go down to cow's milk here
Cow's milk, if you have a sensitivity to k-seed
And you eat hamburger from a cow
There's about a 10% chance that you could actually cross-react to the beef
But you will have about a 90% chance or more of cross-reacting to goat milk
Because the k-seed in goat milk, though it's different, it's very similar
Has a similar amino acid sequence
The chance of you cross-reacting to that is very high
So I know some people that cannot eat any dairy
80 cows, cheese
But they can eat goat cheese
They're not getting the same cross-reacted
Or there might have some immune tolerance to that for a period of time
And then they start reacting to it
They need to take that back onto their diet and calm that immune system down again
So I know it gets confusing
I'm going to give you a list of cross-reactants
To all the different foods that are other lists of the different testing
So that you can look yourself and go, oh that's why I react to this
It's because of, you know, it's a cross-reactant
And known cross-reactant B that it has a very similar amino acid sequence
To the thing that I know that I'm sensitive to
I know I'm sensitive to shellfish and shrimp
That's why I can't eat lobster either
Follow me
Stay with me, it will get simpler
So if the immune reaction to a particular food protein shares a similar sequence of amino acids
With another food protein
The patient may test positive and lab results
Even if the patient is no longer consuming the food
This is really important because I get people that are really upset that might say
I had a person the other day say, come up positive to scallops
And she said, I don't ever eat scallops
I never eat scallops
I've never eaten scallops for 15 years
Why are they testing positive for scallops?
It's because the amino acid sequence in scallops
Is similar to something else they happen to be
consuming at the present time
And that's, and they're reacting to those things in a cross-reactive way
They're developing IGG antibodies to the protein in scallops
Even though they're not eating scallops
So you got to look at the cross-reactive foods
Super important, this is a major thing that people miss
And when you miss this, you go crazy
Because you can't figure out why you have this constant inflammatory process
And I've already eliminated everything in my diet
That the test that I did
Revealed, that's why you look at your test
And you have to look at the cross-reactive list
Because if you're still having problems
When you've eliminated things that were positive on your food sensitivity test
It is most likely because you're still consuming
A cross-reactive food that is a similar amino acid sequence
Hammer this home
Cross-reactivity can occur between dietary proteins
And we just got finished other food proteins
But here's another bad thing
And this can even be worse
Cross-reactivity can occur between dietary proteins and human tissue proteins
Due to molecular mimicry
I use the example with gluten and your thyroid gland
So anybody that's got thyroid issues
Hashimoto's and Graves disease better not be eating gluten
And you should go one step further
And look at all the cross-reactivity foods to gluten
And stay up those two
If you want to stop the destruction of your thyroid gland
And the symptoms that go along with it
You have to look at the molecular mimicry foods
Different proteins in different foods can cross-react with human tissue proteins
Because the molecular mimicry the protein shape
Confirmation is very similar
The antibody binds to both things
If I have TPO antibodies to my thyroid gland
It's going to bind to those
Will bind to gluten and some of the cross-reactants to gluten
And therefore cause an immune reaction
And further destruction of that tissue
Should I consume that dietary protein in this case gluten
So here's a perfect example
You look at these three proteins at the bottom of the slide
They're totally different proteins
But they have very similar look to them
That's what's called molecular mimicry
And the antibody can bind
That same binding site are these three different proteins
And cause that same reaction
Very important
Molecular mimicry is very important
Here's another example
Of shellfish
There's a hundred different proteins in shellfish
So we're talking about shrimp
One of these hundred proteins in shellfish
Is tropomyosid
Tropomyosid is a protein
Also found in your body
It's found in your muscles
So if you have
If you're showing antibodies
You've created antibodies against shrimp
Okay
That is antibodies against tropomyosid in shrimp
You can actually cross-react
When you eat shrimp
It can cross-react
And have those antibodies attack your old muscle cells
Very dangerous
So you're eating shrimp
And you can have them
If people think you're doing a food sensitive
Just because you're trying to get rid of a tummy ache
There's nothing to do with a tummy ache
It can cause a tummy ache
But that's not what we're talking about
We're talking about an auto-immune reaction
So you're eating this shrimp
That you have antibodies against
Be of the test
And then it is firing that antibody
That's attacking the tropomyosid in your own muscles
And damaging your own muscles
So tropomyosid is found in skeletal muscles
This is where your person might say
Oh my gosh, I eat this
And I just ache all over
I don't know what it is
I ache all over
But not only do you have to look at the shellfish
Maybe the shrimp
That you have antibodies against
You have to look at the cross-reactants
To that shrimp
So that you're not eating this thing
And it's causing attack
On your old skeletal muscles
And just eroding your muscles
Bad things
So you look at the cross-reactants
This is interesting
Pulled up the cross-reactant list for shrimp
Is burgodorphine antibodies
So you have antibodies to burgodorphine
Used to that's the main bacterial component of
Lyme disease
You're firing a reaction to anywhere
You have Lyme disease still in your body
Epstein-bar virus
Anti-empty-bar virus antibodies
You have antibodies to shellfish
You're eating shellfish
You're going to react
Your epstein-bar is going to flare up
So not just tropomycin
Also you see it reacts to T3 and T4
So shellfish is going to react to your thyroid
It's so frustrating
What could I not eat anything
We're going to talk about that
We have solutions to that
Calm down
But if you're still having problems
This is how deep you need to dig
Granted, you're not watching this video
If you don't have any symptoms
And you're feeling great
You're probably not watching this video
You're watching this video
Because you have problems
Nobody's been able to figure out
And you ban and spent
You know
tens or hundreds of thousands of dollars
Some people have told us
Well I'm starting to give you some answers
Hopefully
You're digging into the things
That can fire an immune reaction
And cause self-destruction
So remember when you have an autoimmune disease
When you fire an immune reaction
To that
Gland or organ or tissue site
It's causing self-destruction
Self-destruction
You are going down a pathway
Where you could lose all your cells
And be in a situation that it's not very good
That's Parkinson's
That's MS
That's dementia
There's so much destruction of tissue at a certain point
It's not going to regenerate
Some of these tissues don't regenerate very well
You have to put the brakes on it
You have to get serious about this
Stop, that's why we're getting deep into this
Okay, here's another trope of myosin from tilapia
So antibodies against vertebrate trope of myosins
May cross-react with human endogenous
It's your own cells
Your own trope of myosins
In your muscle cells
Autoimmunity to trope of myosins
Have been implicated
In all sorts of colitis
In a lot of different disorders
You're going to see it
I am only pulled up this article right here
But there's multiple articles about
About autoimmune reactions to trope of myosin
And how it affects
Because you have muscles that surround your
Attestile tract
It's a bad thing
You guys
Something you really got to pay attention to
And then this is information about molecular mimicry
With different foods to human tissues
There's a certain human tissue cell called aquaporins
Aquaporins is partly how your cells communicate to one another
It also has their aquaporins
They're bedded in cell membranes
It's how you absorb things through your cells
It's part of the liposolate polysaccharide
Of your cell membranes
All your cells have aquaporins
You have aquaporins in the extracellular matrix
Matrix
If you have immune reactions
If you've created antibodies
To soy aquaporins
Corn aquaporins
Spinach aquaporins
Or tomato aquaporins
They have found
That they actually cross-react
Because of molecular mimicry
To human aquaporins
What kind of symptoms could that cause?
Oh just about anything
Literally just about anything
This could be a major reason
Why a person is absorbing things
Into their cells
That they shouldn't be absorbing into the cells
This could be a major reason
This could be a tie to cancer
This could be a tie to
To just a hyperinflammatory disease
When you have damage to your old aquaporins
You're not going to be able to absorb nutrients into the cell
You're going to have mitochondrial disease and dysfunction
Energy issues
Because you're not going to be able to make energy for self-function
And reproduction
I mean the list goes on and on and on
So testing for these are so important
So important
That's where we talk about the array 3x
The array 4
The array 10
Test for these things
You want to know
You want to know this stuff
So that you stay away from this stuff
So you don't move into any irreversible disorder
Detection of antibodies against human and planet aquaporins
In patients with multiple sclerosis
I threw in a couple of articles here
Hashimoto's same thing
And this actually ties to
Antithoroxyl
Thyro peroxidase
These are TPO antibodies for patients with Hashimoto's
Incephalopathy
We need inflammation of the brain
Because the TPO antibodies bind to cerebellar astrocytes
Astrocytes is a type of glial cell in the brain
Astrocytes throughout the brain
But in the cerebellum, the cerebellum
It's the back part of the brain that controls really fine movement
And basically controls your spine and eyes
Eye movement
And your coordination
So when you end up with inflammation in the cerebellum
And again
Gluten, casin
Stimulating TPO antibodies
It's going to fire to the cerebellum
Because damage to the cerebellum
You're going to start to find
Issues with cerebellar attacksia issues
Very important
So it's not just
Oh, I just damaged the thyroid
And I'm just taking sensoroid
So I'm fine
It's way deeper than that
So pay attention to this stuff
Here's an example of just 10 selected foods
And their degrees of reactivity
With antibodies
Talking about the thyroid
Again, the thyroglobulin T3 and T4
How common it is to have these reactivities
These cross reactions
That equally damage the organ that we're talking about
This is just talking about the thyroid
We could use the same examples
I could pull up examples for the brain
Which gets even scarier
And if you're having any brain issues
And lack of clear thinking
And you know
Complete fatigue can't get off the couch
It gets even more scary
So it's so important to dig in
And find these things
So this is just an example of gluten
So many people think they do not have a gluten sensitivity
You need to do the testing
Just because you don't get a stomach ache
When you eat gluten does not need anything
So the trigger is gluten
You're eating gluten
You might not have any symptoms
From eating gluten
But there is always a target autoimmunity
That's tested for
In the 3x and the 4 array
In this case
In this example
The tri- the transglutaminase 2
It's a human body
An enzyme that's targeted
That causes intestinal issues
Because that's where that is located
And then these people will get a biopsy
They'll see damage to the intestines
And it can be irreversible
And then
As soon as you remove the gluten
Healing can take place
But you have to remove the gluten
There's other transglutaminases
That are affected with gluten
Transglutaminase 3 affects the skin
People end up with skin issues
That can be a psoriasis type issue
Transglutaminase 6 is the scariest
It directly affects the cerebellum
Even if the person has no TPO antibodies
That we discussed a couple of slides before
So you end up with cerebellum
Ataxia
This is part of your brain
And when you have decay or degeneration
Neural tissue
Neural tissue does not regenerate very well
This can be permanent damage
And we don't want that
So pay attention to these things
So we're talking about array 3
It measures these transglutaminases
Measures if you have antibodies
To the transglutaminases already
And then it measures other gluten proteins
Remember if you did a food sensitive test
Through some place else and they test for gluten
And it just said Gliadinus was negative
That really means nothing
You have to look at the peptide
So without getting too complicated here
A protein
The protein of gluten is Gliadin
And that's a very long chain protein
They give it a long chain of beads on a pearl necklace
And all those beads are amino acids
So that's what a protein is
Is a specific sequence of amino acids
That's what a protein is
And then as you chew that up and gobble it up and swallow it
You've broken some of that protein into different parts of protein
That's the whole idea of digestion
You think of it as you're snipping apart
Different, you know, that whole chain of that pearl necklace
Now those are called peptides
So you have to do at a
At a mutant pedal that's going to measure the Gliadin peptides
These are all the Gliadin peptides listed here
So it will snip it apart in certain ways
So you have enzymes
that enter into your, that come from your
piranha gland
When you start chewing food
And you have HCl in your stomach
And then enzymes that are secreted into your duodenum
That are made by your, by your pancreas
You have enzymes that are coming from your liver
And from your bile
That's breaking down your food
The case of gluten, it's breaking down Gliadin
Into its different peptides
And all the way down to an amino acid sequence
That's a single amino acid
Or a double amino acid
Two together called a dipeptide
And that's how we're supposed to absorb them
The problem is we have damage gut wall
We absorb these peptides that are larger sequences
These 15, more, 17, more, 33, more peptides
And then our, our body, our immune system looks at them
And goes what in the heck are you
We need to make an antibody against it
to kill it. Will it ever kill? It's not a living organism. No, now you have circulated antibodies
to alpha-glyaden-33-mer. And every time you eat gluten, it's going to break it down into alpha-glyaden-33-mer
before it finally breaks it down to an amino acid. If you have an adequate digestive enzyme concentration,
but you'll have a reaction, you'll have an immune reaction to the alpha-glyaden-33-mer. If you have
antibodies to alpha-glyaden-33-mer, because antibodies are going to be throughout your bloodstream
and in the little bit of the intestines. Well, I know that was a lot. You have to rewind and listen
to that again, do it about four or five times, because this is super important. You have to measure
peptides. You have to measure the peptides, not just glyaden. The chance that you have a sensitivity
to just glyaden is not very high. That means glyaden, the entire giant molecule of that protein had
to get through across the gut border. Then you really know you have a damaged gut border
in order for you to create antibodies against that in order for you to fire an immune reaction against
that. Whether you really got problems, most likely you have antibodies, IgG and IgA antibodies,
and you should have to do a test that measures both of those that against the different peptides.
Super important array, 3X measures that. If you have exposure to gluten, you could have a
immune reaction against gluten in a couple of different ways with interopathy, meaning damage to the
gut. You might have a immune reaction that you see and you feel damaged to the gut could cause tissue
inflammation, could cause gluteumorphine reaction, which fires directly to the brain, and it's going
to affect your neurochemical imbalance. It's going to cause brain fog, brain issues,
damage to the brain, cerebellar attacks and things like that that we just discussed. You could also
have tissue autoimmunity. It could cross-react with myelin antibodies if you you should test for
these too. This is the array 7X. We'll talk about that in another video. cerebellum antibodies,
parietal cell antibodies, islet cell antibodies causing pancreatic issues and diabetes,
thyroid peroxidase antibodies. This is causing Hashimoto's. It's going to react directly with
Hashimoto's, like we talked about. It can cause issues with your heart and trinsic factor. You're
not going to absorb B12. You could have an autoimmune reaction to the trinsic factor, and that's why you
have fatigue issues because you're not absorbing B12 no matter how much B12 you have. It can react
with GAN antibodies, so you can overexcite the GAN gene and you're producing way too much glutamate
from glutamine consumption. Now, your glutamate factor raises very high in your brain, which is the
major cause of ADD-ADHD, at least one major cause of it, the major cause of anxiety issues. It
well, if you have any cancer in your brain, it is a major fuel source for cancer,
brain cancer. So you talk about, okay, this only has to do with stomach problems. If I
included, hopefully I'm drilling this into you that you have to test for all these other things
because it could be far more implicated from stomach problems to something more serious.
But let's say, oh, I don't have any enteropathy, any damage to my gut when I eat gluten. So without
enteropathy, the right side of that screen, you could have HLADQ2 or 8 genotypes. That's your gene
profile can lead to full blown celiac disease without that genotype. It can lead to later gluten
enteropathy over time. Remember, you're going through this autoimmune reaction. You have this,
you know, stage one, stage two, stage three. You can flip from stage one to stage three quite quickly.
This is the array 3x from Syrex. It tests all these different things that we went over before.
And remember, the yellow is one range equivalent over normal. Two is the red. That doesn't necessarily
need the severity of the person's problem. It really means the severity of how many antibodies
you're creating. But how many antibodies you're creating to that thing does not necessarily equate
to your reaction and your problem with it. So we talked about that before.
So it goes way beyond gluten. It goes through all the different cross-reactants, all the different
foods that you could look at. This is the array 4 where you're looking at all the cross-reactivity
to gluten. How you could, well, I've gluten-free, but I chocolate and I'm still having brain fog,
or I mean drinking coffee or sesame or whatever it possibly is. You want to look at the big picture.
These are the reasons why I've done everything and I still can't get better. The truth is,
you didn't do everything. We didn't look at everything. So we need to keep digging and looking.
And I would rather give you the power to do these tests and look at themselves and make the changes
yourselves. So you don't have to spend, you know, a fortune and a doctor about saying you shouldn't go
to a doctor, but then these are things that you have to do. You have to make those dietary changes.
So I'm empowering you with this information. This is the array 4 test where it tests the cross
reactivities. The other one was the array 3x. And this is really what we're looking at. Testinal
permeability, that's leaky gut syndrome. You damaged your intestinal wall cells. So they're separated.
You're absorbing things that you should never absorb. You have peptides that should never have gotten
through. That's how you create these sensitivities gluten reactivity. You know, it's a negative cycle
causes a greater intestinal permeability. I don't really have a problem. So I just a little bit of gluten
caused more fire in the gut even though you felt nothing. And it's causing more intestinal permeability.
It's ramping up the autoimmunity at the bottom line. So you're getting immune cross reactivity,
cross-reactive foods. You're getting cross-reactive autoimmune sites in your body. And then
you're just causing, you know, ramped up loss of self-tolerance. You're going to become more,
more sensitive to more things, more, more sensitive to these are the people that are sensitive to EMS.
They're sensitive to smells. They're sensitive to any type of chemical. They're sensitive. You have
to help build self-tolerance. These people have lost all self-tolerance. And the best place to start
is food. Well, I'm so sensitive to smells. I can't go in stores. Well, then you have to get back to
the food because you have to eat food every day, right? So that is where you're getting, you know,
you think you're getting a little bit of smell when you walk into a store. Think how much chemistry
is changing when you eat a food. So we have to dig in and do this testing once we can start healing
the body and getting rid of that immune reaction or slowly that immune reaction. You'll start to build
self-tolerance and you can, you know, start tolerating, walking in a store. There's other things
that the dietary things that can stimulate an immune reaction to. So we talked about different
foods, cross-reactivities, getting tested for those things. But there's more data coming out on
other things. Salt drives autoimmune disease by inducing pathological TH17 cells. So it's
stimulating the cytokine TH17, which is a hyperinflammatory cytokine response.
Happened. It affects the brain, affects your joints, affects a lot of different tissues.
And some people have that sensitivity worth eating too much salt can cause a can can flare their
autoimmune disease. Eating too much salt can flare your autoimmune disease. Multiple studies coming out
of this. Interested correlative study showed that patients with autoimmune disease should try to
consume potassium if they notice they react to salty food. So this shouldn't be necessarily everybody
with an autoimmune issue. And if they're going to eat salty foods, they should take potassium too.
But if you notice why? I know that I never thought of that and I do love chips. I thought it was
the corn chips. Maybe it's the salt, not the corn chips that you're eating. I did the test. I
don't have any reactivity to corn. It is a cross-reacted and I stayed away from corn. I can eat corn bread,
but I can eat those salty chips. It may be the sodium. Try consuming potassium. But you have to consume.
The study showed you have to consume about a thousand milligrams of potassium. And most potassium
supplements are only going to contain about a hundred milligrams. So you'd have to take about ten of them.
On our story, we have a powdered potassium that a teaspoon contains twelve hundred milligrams. So
just try it. Try taking about a thousand milligrams of potassium and eat those corn chips again
or whatever chips or salty food you're eating that you seem to constantly react to and see if that
diminishes the reaction. And that salt is the bad guy in your diet. So something that you need to
clinically look at. You need to observe these things. You need to pay attention to these things.
We need to get you off the couch and feeling better again.
Food coloring. It's another thing that's a big, big immune stimulant that can cause a flare in your
immune system that could cause a ramped up autoimmune reaction. And certainly neurobehavioral
disorders. This is very common with parents see this with their kids with autism or any type of
autism spectrum disorder. Food coloring can be a major reactivity because it fires in a immune reaction.
So if food coloring does do this, then you know you have self-antibodies on guaranteed
and doing a self-antibody test would be would be important. Okay, we're doing really well.
We only got a few slides left. Digestive enzymes. How important are digestive enzymes? Remember what
it protein is. So when we're talking about food sensitivities, we're talking about IGG,
IGG, IGA reactions to proteins. It's a reaction to a protein in the food or as the protein breaks down
it's a reaction to the part of the protein that is called a peptide. So a peptide is a portion
of a protein. So use gliadin as an example again. Okay, we could use any food protein because it's the
same with any food protein. But again, gliadin is the protein of gluten and the peptides. There's
multiple peptides that breaks down to that you can be reacted to. So but if you had a really healthy
gut, plenty of adequate HCl in your stomach. Plenty of health in your in your in your pro in your
enzyme production of your pancreas and secretion of those enzymes into your small intestine. Plenty of
health of your liver and creating healthy bile, secreting that into your doandal tract as well
that you would more adequately break down the proteins down to their final product which is
an amino acid or a dipeptide two amino acids bonded together. You will never have a reaction. You do
not develop antibodies to amino acids. You develop antibodies to peptides. So that's why I've said
over and over again for decades, the most important supplement to take is HCl and digestive enzymes.
The bottom line most if you could only take one supplement, it would be HCl and digestive enzymes.
And to me the US enzymes brand digestive enzymes and there's just there's nothing like a matter
fact. The paired company of US enzymes actually makes a lot of enzymes for a lot of other nutritional
companies. So you may be actually taking the enzymatic you paired company US enzymes, paired
company in your digestive enzyme. But here are the US enzymes digestive enzymes. HClzyme which is HCl
plus a broad spectrum digestive enzyme. Glutinzyme is the best anti-gleadin enzyme there is. It has
all this all the needed enzymes to help break down gluten and some of the cross-reactants have gluten
but digestive enzymes plus is by far the best broad spectrum enzyme on the market the digestive enzymes
just hands down there's nothing like it. So taking these, how should I take them? Should I take them
before food? Should I take them with food after food? The best way to take your enzymes is right before
you're going to eat. Have it you're stomach so it's there before you eat. If you ate and you oh I forgot
to take it, you could take it. That's it's going to get in there. It's going to help break down that
food. If you ate half an hour ago, oh, crud, can I still take my HCl's on? Yeah, you're getting to that
edge of that food might have already emptied your stomach into the small intestine. You're going to
kind of miss it with the HCl's. I'm still you could probably take a digestime and a gluteus I will
get into the duodenum it into the intestinal tract but you're going to miss some of that food. So
best to take it with your meal best best is right before your meal. Even if you don't you know buy
these you can buy these on our store but if you don't buy these if you have enzymes at home certainly
take enzymes make sure you keep your enzymes out of the sun. They can degrade, make sure you keep them
in a cool place in your house. Enzyme is probably the most important nutritional supplement that you
can be taking. And then I want to touch on a few other foods. The role of night chains in auto
immunity, night chains, eggplant, tomatoes, bell peppers, and other peppers, not black pepper.
Contained alkaloid properties. They also contain lectin properties. We'll talk about lectins in a
minute too. Lectin is a major problem with lectin is that it causes a glute nation, a glute nation
is remember what I talked about is the combination of different proteins and the combination of
different peptides to actually form a neoprotein in themselves which is a new protein that your immune
system can react to. That's the problem with lectins. So lectin can lead to bacterial overgrowth,
can damage the gut wall and can affect because of the neoprotein formation that a glute nation
issue with lectins. So these are lectin foods that you may want to look at. Maybe that's my problem.
It's mainly a glute nation. It's the combination causing neoproteins and I want to experiment with
a state away from some lectin foods. Okay, we talked about a glute nation with lectins,
roll of lectins happens for me these new proteins that then I end up having an immune response
against. So what do you do? This is so confusing and so depressing. I wonder if someone has smashed
my head against the wall. Well, don't give up. So you've been dealing with this for a long time.
My opinion is you get tested through the Syrex array 3x, the Syrex 4, the Syrex 10. If you want to
test for antibodies and look at the other video on that you can, if you're going to get a blood draw
for these you can do the Syrex 7x which tests for neurological antibodies, Syrex 5 which tests for
other tissue antibodies. I think those are all so valuable tests. How much are all those tests
together? You'll spend less than $2,000 for those tests and you'll know you know at least a starting
point on what to do and moving forward. There's just so much value there. So and it's things that I
making videos on all these tests so that you can then you don't need to schedule an appointment with
anybody. You can then look at those tests and interpret themselves. Look at the cross-reactive
lists. You can start doing some self-investigation on your own diet and oh my gosh, maybe that's why
I react when I eat pineapple. I never thought of it that way before and now I know it's because it's
a cross-reactive than this and so you'll be able to be your own investigator. That's what this whole
courses are for. Therefore to empower you to be your own investigator and to be your own doctor not
that you don't seek the help of a doctor. We highly recommend that but we want you to be empowered
and that you're not that you're educated. So I think there's huge value in that. So down to the last
few slides here, promise you. So dietary considerations is autoimmunity for sure. Let's say I can't afford
any of these tests. I am just total broke ski. Whether you definitely go off glue to definitely go
off dairy. Download the cross-reactive tests. Look at going grain-free, going night-shade-free, going
lectin-free and you can't just do it for a week and think oh that didn't really help. You have to do it
for a period of time, months even to see if you notice them call me down in your immune system and
this is where you have to write down how you're feeling. Keep a diary of how you're feeling.
You have to absolutely bottom line start with a gluten-free diet. Go to a paleo diet, go to an
autoimmune paleo diet. If you don't have the ability to test further, cross-reactive foods
download the forms from the Syrex that I'll have on here. The cross-reactive foods start
eliminating some of those. Think about reducing sodium in your diet. That's salt. Could that be the
problem? I didn't talk about stabilizing blood glucose but that's an issue too. If you're eating
a lot of sugar and your glucose is bouncing around, that's an issue that can stimulate an immune
reaction. Not bad to go to target by yourself a little glucometer that you can test your blood
glucose level in the morning and post-prangil. That can be very helpful to help monitor and self
take care of you. Basic intestinal permeability diet. This is a slide you want to memorize.
Avoid gluten. Avoid interior. Avoid processed foods. Fast foods. Fried foods. You're eating a lot
of vegetables and fruit. Fermented foods. Rice and gluten. Healthy oils. Meets. Of course.
I don't like this. I can't eat fermented foods. I have a histamine issue. Okay, well,
but ain't that too. That you're getting into a more comprehensive diet. You're doing some testing.
You're staying completely grain-free. You're staying dairy-free. You're staying away from
particles of dairy like whey, whey proteins. Stayed away from GMO foods. So it's corn and soy and
so you're getting more specific in an autoimmune paleo diet. That's what this is called. This is a great
way to start. If you can't do the testing, you're still having problems. You can't get off the
couch. You have never dealt with these things. You need to dig into them. Even if your diet is I can
all eat four foods. Get tested because if you're eating the same four foods all the time, there's a very
strong possibility. Your gut is just destroyed because you don't have the, you know, you're not getting
good probiotic array of bacteria growing in your gut because of your lack of foods in your diet.
So this is the array three again. This is the array four again and this is the array ten
which gives you all the different foods. Not the specificity that you get with array three and four.
Some people just do array ten but I'd highly suggest the combination of array three, four and ten.
There is a discount for those two and it will give you that discount forward to you if you need
to get that. So again, we're looking at the stages of autoimmunity trying to keep you in that silent
stage. If you already have elevated antibodies and if you already are in stage three with tissue
destruction, we're trying to quell that tissue destruction, calm that down, calm down the inflammation
that's going to help calm down all your symptoms so that you can get your life back and live again.
But this isn't something that I did this for a period of time and I'm all better now I can go back to
eat, jug can do it all the stuff. This is a lifestyle change as long as you have autoimmunity
which is forever. So these are lifestyle changes that you're going to get your life back. You have to
be willing to do the work. No doctors going to magically erase it. No magic pill is going to erase it.
No magic supplements going to erase it. No magic drug is going to erase it. This is work that you
have to do. So stay with me, watch our other videos that go into details and how to interpret the
different arrays from Syrex so that you can self take care of yourself, try to empower you and
do it everything. Know that we're praying for you. Hope this is the help. Bye bye.